the first question is most ill-advised
fashion purchase once I was walking down
the street in Beverly Hills and so I
just felt like everything was fancy this
car pulled up and this little Italian
guy jumped out and he was talking so
fast and told me I had to buy one of
these leather jackets he had in the
trunk of his of his car that I
immediately just thought he must be
telling the truth
and I was like yeah I don't I don't
think I need a leather jacket and he's
like no no no these are Armani jackets
it's just when they come directly from
Italy they don't say Armani
he told me is like you dawn time to try
it on you just have to buy one of these
and for whatever reason I just thought
yeah I think I think I do have to buy
one of these I actually said you know I
don't have the cash on me I need to go
to the ATM and I went walked a few
blocks to an ATM machine came back gave
him a couple hundred dollars but and I
remember I got home and my girlfriend
looked at the leather jacket I just
bought and just said that's that's
terrif that is a terrible it I don't
even think that's real leather
that was a bad purchase I never even
wore it